welcome to the man of recaps this is
peacemaker season one peacemaker is a
spin-off series of the suicide squad
movie no not suicide squad from 2016
they already made a reboot which was
much more of a comedy you don't need to
know anything from the movie just a
basic premise they take super-powered
prisoners and send them on dangerous
missions john cena plays christopher
smith peacemaker he's a hero who fights
for peace but his whole motto is he
doesn't care how many people he has to
kill to get it and now he's got his own
series with a ridiculously hilarious
opening credits dance that perfectly
captures the tone of the show so after
his last mission peacemaker returns home
hoping for some peace and quiet but the
us government's not done with him yet
they've got his next mission lined up
code name project butterfly the team
leader is mirn badass girl is harcourt
nerdy computer guys john economos then
there's the rookie leota adobayo who's
never worked in black ops before it's
kind of unclear how she got this job
turns out she's the daughter of amanda
waller director of argus who sent her
here on a double secret mission now the
team chemistry is not great because
peacemaker is kind of a dick he makes
fun of economists for dying his beard
and hits on harcourt which she does not
appreciate he just got out of prison
though and is looking for a hookup and
after finding one he's feeling good
until this woman tries to kill him and
oh she's got super strength it's an epic
underwear fight and peacemaker barely
makes it out of there he grabs his super
helmet and manages to defeat her with
its sonic boom this causes quite a scene
so they've gotta cover it up and frame
someone else unfortunately the first
person they thought of to frame was
peacemaker's father which might
complicate things peacemaker's dad is a
real bad dude who gives his son negative
love and respect and he really messed
chris up by training him to kill since
he was a kid and he's not just a really
bad dude he's a white supremacist super
villain the white dragon peacemaker
craves some parental love but he's never
gonna get it so sometimes he just breaks
down and cries his best friend of course
is eagerly his pet eagle and sidekick
but his human best friend is vigilante
another anti-hero who murders bad guys
but peacemakers having a crisis right
now he doesn't really want to kill
people anymore vigilante no such issues
he's fully insane so it's finally time
for their first mission they want
peacemaker to assassinate a u.s senator
and maybe his whole family peacemaker's
not okay with killing kids even when
it's apparent oh they're aliens luckily
vigilante tagged along and has no issues
taking them all out but before he could
finish the job the senator's bodyguards
here to stop him it's judo master a
small guy with epic kung fu skills and
beats them all up so peacemaker's
captured and judo master eats flamin hot
cheetos over the course of the season
judo masters captured and escapes
multiple times but always finds himself
some flaming hot cheetos alien senator
is interrogating peacemaker to make
peacemaker talk he tortures his best
friend vigilante but it's like don't
worry man i know you can take it i'll
never break eventually peacemaker
escapes and shoots this guy and turns
out the alien possessing him is a
literal butterfly yes it's your classic
invasion of the body snatchers the
butterflies can only eat the special
nectar though and now they've found
where it's bottled they want to do a
stealth mission so no chainsaws but
peacemaker puts on his x-ray vision
helmet and turns out everyone in here is
a butterfly so very quickly the stealth
mission fails and peacemaker pulls out
his homemade weapon a grenade strapped
to a tank shell which causes a bigger
explosion than he anticipated then they
fight a butterfly possessed gorilla and
they're only saved because john economos
comes in with the chainsaw after this
victory the team is bonded they're
rocking out together even harcourt's
having fun she's gotten to know chris
and discovered that under his alpha dick
persona he's kind of a softy chris and
adebayo become best friends there's no
sexual tension she's a happily married
lesbian but she has a secret the mission
from her mother to plant a fake
peacemaker diary to frame him for this
whole operation peacemaker has a secret
too he didn't actually kill the
senator's butterfly he kept it as a pet
cause he's crazy and mirn has the
biggest secret of all when leota's
messing around with the x-ray vision she
sees that he is a butterfly but he's a
good butterfly who doesn't approve of
taking over humanity and is trying to
stop him meanwhile the evidence finally
clears peacemaker's father and leads the
cops towards peacemaker himself but as
they're escaping through the trees
vigilante falls accidentally freeing the
butterfly which possesses this cop and
this one is the butterfly leader that
calls in reinforcements possesses the
whole police station and unfortunately
the fake diary does its job of framing
peacemaker now he's america's most
wanted but first bad dad wants his
revenge white dragon comes in ready to
kill his son and we finally see
peacemaker's full tragic backstory he
had a brother but his father made them
fight and one day he accidentally killed
him and he's been harboring that guilt
all his life but now he finally accepts
it wasn't his fault it was his father's
and so peacemaker kills his evil father
and has an emotional breakthrough and
breakdown but meanwhile the butterflies
track down mirn and kill him for
betraying them now the team's without
their leader it's up to our crew of
misfits to save the world turns out all
of their nectar comes from one source
the cow a giant alien bug thing so the
team goes to assault the farm the plan
is to use peacemaker sonic boom helmet
to blow it up and who's gonna get it
over there it's eagley's time to shine
yes it looks like peacemaker actually
gets him to carry it oh but no he goes
the wrong way plan b is john economos
the one team member the butterflies
won't recognize he gets it into position
but unfortunately of course things go
wrong but they still manage to activate
the sonic boom oh yeah now it's time for
the all-out assault yes epic final
action scene our crew is badass
peacemaker goes down to finish off the
cow unfortunately he ends up buried in
rubble and up top vigilante and harcourt
are both grievously injured so it's up
to leota adobayo to go in there guns
blazin and save the day she goes down to
save peacemaker from the butterfly
leader with his human torpedo helmet
which doesn't work well it's still a
prototype but the butterfly leader
doesn't want to fight she's like look
peacemaker we're the good guys their
planet was destroyed from climate change
by corporate greed and she's like
earth's going down the same path we're
not trying to enslave humanity we're
trying to save it we just want peace
this resonates with peacemaker it's a
tough choice but in the end he activates
human torpedo cause leota's over here
and all launched into the cow so the day
is saved from an alien invasion slash
intervention and now that the battle's
over who should show up but the justice
league all season long peacemaker has
been talking smack about him saying how
he's met him and they're all dicks now
he tells aquaman to go bang a fish and
turns out these aren't just fake shadow
cameos it's jason momoa and the flash
ezra miller and so our team is bruised
and battered but gonna be okay even the
final butterfly with nowhere else to go
comes to be peacemaker's pet adebayo
apologizes for betraying peacemaker with
the diary she's like hey man you're my
real friend now she calls a press
conference exposing project butterfly
and that peacemaker is really a hero and
so peacemaker has saved the day gone on
a journey to become a better person and
that's where peacemaker season 1 comes
to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you'd
love this recap check out the join
button and support the channel as a
member